LOT OF NEW INFORMATION AND
THAT WILL BE COMING EITHER
BY THE END OF THIS MONTH OR
EARLY NEXT MONTH.
ALL RIGHT, JOINING US HERE
AT CPAC WITH REACTION,
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO
THE PRESIDENT, GIVE HIM A
BIG HAND, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, NATIONAL
SECURITY STRATEGIST
SEBASTIAN GORKA.
AND FORMER SECRET SERVICE
AGENT, NRA TV CONTRIBUTOR
DAN BONGINO.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> HOW ARE YOU DOING,
BROTHER.
WELCOME TO CPAC.
THEY ALL LIKE FREE
FOOTBALLS.
>> ME, TOO.
>> Sean: LET ME START WITH
THE YEAR THAT HAS BEEN.
YOU WERE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
IN THE BEGINNING OF THIS.
HERE YOU HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
TURN AROUND IN THE ECONOMY.
YOU KNOW, ALL IN 2016,
DR. GORKA I SAID TO MY
AUDIENCE.
I SAID EVERY DAY AND DID I
IT ON PURPOSE NOT TO HEAR
MYSELF TALK.
I SAID OH, WE HAVE, WHAT,
13 MILLION MORE AMERICANS ON
FOOD STAMPS.
8 MILLION MORE ON POVERTY
AFTER 8 YEARS IN OBAMA.
WORST RECOVERY SINCE THE
40S.
LOWEST LABOR PARTICIPATION
RATE SINCE THE 1970S, WE
DOUBLED THE NATIONAL DEBT
AND LOWEST HOME OWNERSHIP
RATE IN 51 YEARS, IN ONE
YEAR THIS DRAMATIC CHANGE
HAS OCCURRED.
BUT IT'S NOT REPORTED ON.
WHY?
>> WHY?
BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF THE
MEDIA IS IN THE TANK FOR
HILLARY CLINTON, THE DNC.
AND LET'S JUST BE VERY
CLEAR, IF WE DIDN'T HAVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TWITTER
FEED OR ASHANTE, HILLARY
CLINTON WOULD BE PRESIDENT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: I'M A CONVERT BY
THE WAY.
THERE WERE TIMES I SAID OH,
PLEASE DON'T TWEET THAT, NO,
NO, NO.
>> HE WON.
HE IS UP TO 47 MILLION
FOLLOWERS.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU ADD ALL
THE SOCIAL MEDIA IT'S LIKE
OVER.
>> JUST ON TWITTER.
>> WHY?
BECAUSE IS HE JUMPING OVER
THE FAKE NEWS INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX AND SAYING LOOK,
THIS IS THE TRUTH.
DO YOU WANT TO DEFEAT ISIS?
DO YOU WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE
JOBS?
[APPLAUSE]
DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE THE
BORDER?
WHAT IS IT THAT DEMOCRATIC
PARTY GOING TO RUN ON
AGENDA.
DON'T WANT JOBS AND DON'T
WANT GROWTH AND ISIS SHOULD
COME BACK?
IS THAT WHAT THEY'RE GOING
TO RUN ON?
>> Sean: THEY ARE GOING TO
RUN ON I HATE DONALD TRUMP.
>> BINGO.
NOT EVEN THE RUSSIA THING IS
WORKING FOR THEM.
WHERE IS THE COLLUSION,
SEAN?
THE COLLUSION IS IN THE DNC.
IT'S HILLARY, HER LAWYERS, A
FOREIGN MI 6 SPY, NOT
REGISTERED AS A FOREIGN
AGENT.
>> Sean: WAIT A MINUTE FARK
MATTERS?
>> IT'S A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT, IF IT'S A
DEMOCRAT CANDIDATE IT DOES
NOT.
THINK ONE MORE THING,
$13 MILLION, I MEAN, THAT'S
A PRETTY GOOD -- THAT'S THE
KIND OF JOB I WOULD LIKE.
FOR ONE FILE?
THAT'S MADE UP.
IT'S PROPAGANDA THAT CAME
FROM WHERE?
RUSSIA.
RUSSIA, OKAY.
SO THEY COLLUDED TO
UNDERMINE OUR ELECTION.
I WILL JUST CLOSE ON THIS
AND LET DAN TALK.
IF YOU DIDN'T BELIEVE IN
GOD, WELL, YOU HAVE TO
CHANGE YOUR MIND ON NOVEMBER
THE 7TH, RIGHT?
I MEAN, IT JUST [APPLAUSE]
>> WE HAD DIVINE
INTERVENTION.
SHE HAD THE MEDIA.
SHE HAD THE DEEP STATE.
$1.4 BILLION ON GUESS WHO
WON IN THE OUTSIDER WON.
THE GOD BLESS DONALD TRUMP.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: WELL SAID.
DAN, IT'S BEEN AND I
REMEMBER I WAS HERE IN 2015.
WHEN ALL OF THIS GOT STARTED
UP ON THIS STAGE I
INTERVIEWED DONALD TRUMP,
TED CRUZ, MARCO RUBIO, RAND
PAUL.
>> SURE.
>> Sean: ALL THESE
CANDIDATES.
HERE WE ARE WE HAVE HAD A
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT AND
TURN AROUND IN A YEAR I WANT
TO ASK THE SAME QUESTION, NO
CREDIT GIVEN.
WHAT'S EVEN WORSE IS WE HAVE
BEEN LIED TO OVER A YEAR.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF
THIS.
BUT THERE IS EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION, PAY FOR A RUSSIAN
DOSSIER.
THE URANIUM ONE DEAL IS
UNCONSCIONABLE.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: WE'RE GOING TO TALK
TONIGHT WITH THE LAWYER FOR
THE INFORMANT THAT WAS ON
THE INSIDE.
WHERE ARE WE IN TERMS OF AN
INFORMATION CRISIS?
>> WELL, IT'S BAD, SEAN.
I ALWAYS THINK LIKE WHAT'S
THE DEMOCRATS' SLOGAN?
WHAT'S THE HEADLINE I CALL
IT THE WHEATY'S BOX MESSAGE
FOR THE MID TERMS?
IT'S GOING TO BE DEMS 2018,
CRUMBS AND COLLUSION, VOTE
FOR US.
THAT'S ALL THEY HAVE.
THE IRONY OF THIS WHOLE
THING IS THE DEMOCRATS
PRODUCE CRUMBS UNDER THE
OBAMA ERA.
SEAN, NUMBERS DON'T LIE.
SOONER OR LATER THEY ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO COME TO
ACCEPT THE FACT THAT THEIR
SECULAR STAGNATION THEORY,
IN OTHER WORDS, IT WASN'T
OBAMA'S FAULT.
THE ECONOMY JUST STUNK FOR
ALL KINDS OF SECULAR REASONS
IS DONE.
IT'S ONE YEAR IN OFFICE AND
WE HAVE HAD THREE QUARTERS
NOW OF 3% GROWTH.
OBAMA NEVER HIT IT AT ALL.
THE NUMBERS DON'T LIE.
THE OBAMAITES AND OBAMA FILE
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
RECONCILE THAT ON THE
COLLUSION FRONT.
COLLUSION IS REAL.
DON'T ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM
DON'T THINK RUSSIAN
COLLUSION DIDN'T HAPPEN.
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN WITH THE
TRUMP TEAM.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
QUESTION RIGHT NOW THAT
HILLARY CLINTON DEALT WITH A
FOREIGN AGENT IN CHRISTOPHER
STEELE.
HE IS BRITISH.
HE IS NOT FROM THE UNITED
STATES.
WHO, IN TURN, DEALT WITH
RUSSIAN SOURCES.
AND I'M TELLING YOU, YOU
KNOW THE TICK TOCK ON THIS
ONE.
THERE IS A LOT MORE TO COME
ABOUT STEELE'S INTERACTIONS
WITH THE RUSSIANS THAT YOU
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT WILL
DEEPLY DISTURB EVEN THE MOST
SKEPTICAL PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM.
>> Sean: THIS IS THE THING
THAT I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HERE.
TO ME, THIS IS THE BIGGEST
STORY THAT THE MEDIA HAS
MISSED IN THEIR LIFETIME.
IF YOU HAVE A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE AND WE REALLY,
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO CARE THAT
THE RUSSIANS ARE TRYING TO
INFLUENCE THE ELECTION.
AND THEN ONE CANDIDATE PAYS
FOR RUSSIAN LIES.
AND THEN IT'S USED TO GET A
FISA WARRANT.
THEY DON'T TELL THE FISA
JUDGE THAT HILLARY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR IT THERE
IS A FOOTNOTE THAT SAYS
MIGHT HAVE SOME POLITICAL
TAINTING.
IT WASN'T POLITICAL
SO, THAT HAPPENS IN OCTOBER.
IN JANUARY, COMEY IS TELLING
THE PRESIDENT ELECT IT'S
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED.
BUT THEY ARE TELLING A FISA
COURT IN OCTOBER THAT IT'S
GOOD ENOUGH TO GET A WARRANT
TO SPY ON A MEMBER,
ASSOCIATE OF THE CAMPAIGN.
>> LOOK.
THE BOTTOM LINE HERE IS
THERE IS A REASON THAT IN
1776 WE DID NOT CREATE AN
INTERNAL POLITICAL POLICE
FORCE.
AMERICA DOESN'T HAVE AN
MI-5.
WE DON'T HAVE A SECRET
POLICE THAT SPIES ON
AMERICANS.
IF YOU HAVE PROOF, IF YOU
HAVE PROBABLE CAUSE THAT
SOMEBODY IS DOING SOMETHING,
YOU HAVE TO GO TO A SPECIAL
SECRET COURT AND SAY, LOOK,
THIS IS PRETTY
INCONTROVERTIBLE THAT
SOMETHING SUSPICIOUS IS
GOING ON HERE AND WE'LL
ALLOW YOU TEMPORARILY TO SPY
ON AMERICANS.
BUT, WHAT HAPPENED?
WE NOW KNOW THAT HAPPENED
ILLEGALLY.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
THE HIGHEST PEOPLE IN THE
FBI AND THE DOJ SIGNED OFF
ON THAT WARRANT APPLICATION.
WE HAVE HAD NINE PEOPLE IN
JUST THE LAST TWO MONTHS BE
RETIRED, MOVE TO OTHER
POSITIONS, OR FIRED.
STEVE: HIGHER THAN 9.
I THINK WE ARE UP TO
12-6R7B8G9S THAT'S EVEN
WORSE.
>> Sean: HOW DOES PETER
STRZOK OR LISA PAGE HAVE A
JOB?
PEOPLE ARE AWARE WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE.
>> LOOK, I REFUSE TO USE THE
PHRASE DEEP STATE UNTIL
ABOUT THREE MONTHS AGO.
SAWN SEAN DID YOU REALLY?
WHY?
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS A LITTLE
BIT TIN FOIL HATIE.
>> Sean: SO YOU THOUGHT I
WAS A LITTLE TIN FOIL HATIE.
>> WHEN I SAW THE TEXT
MESSAGE COME OUT.
WHEN YOU BUILT IT UP ON YOUR
MONOLOGUES I PRAY ONE DAY
THAT THE TEXT OF YOUR
MONOLOGUES FOR THE PAST FOUR
MONTHS WILL BE USED IN A
COURT OF LAW TO SEND PEOPLE
TO JAIL.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: IF WE HAVE EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: THERE WILL BE
PEOPLE, A LOT OF THEM THAT
WILL GO TO JAIL.
TRUE OR FALSE?
>> I THINK SO.
AND I THINK THE NEXT SHOE TO
DROP IN THIS, SEAN, WHERE
THOSE 302S CHANGE.
WHAT ARE 302S?
>> Sean: THIS IS IMPORTANT
WHAT DAN BONGINO IS SAYING
HERE, PAY VERY CLOSE
ATTENTION.
I WAS THERE WHEN.
>> WHEN YOU HEARD IT.
>> Sean: THIS IS GOING TO
COME OUT.
>> WHEN I WAS IN THE SECRET
SERVICE AFTER DID YOU AN
INTERVIEW, YOU DIDN'T HAVE
TO FILL OUT AN OFFICIAL
FORMAL FORM YOU FILLED IT
OUT ON A WORD DOCUMENT.
THE FBI HAS A FORM CALLED
THE 302.
THAT INFORMATION ON MIKE
FLYNN AND ON THE INTERVIEWS
OF HILLARY CLINTON.
THERE WERE 302S THERE.
THE BIG QUESTION IS GOING TO
BE WERE THOSE 302S CHANGED?
BECAUSE IF THE FBI AGENTS IN
THAT ROOM AND I KNOW WHO
BOTH OF THEM WERE, WHO
INTERVIEWED MIKE FLYNN, BOTH
CAME OUT OF THERE, ONE OF
THEM AT LEAST CAME OUT OF
THERE WITH THE OPINION THAT
MIKE FLYNN DID NOT LIE TO
THEM IN THAT INTERVIEW.
SOMEONE IS GOING TO HAVE A
WHOLE LOT OF --
>> Sean: WHAT HAS HAPPENED
TO GENERAL FLYNN IS NOTHING
SHORT OF A NATIONAL
DISGRACE.
>> IT WAS HORRIBLE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: WHAT THEY HAVE DONE
TO HIM.
SURVEILLANCE, UNHAVOCKING,
NO MINIMALIZATION.
>> THE LOGAN ACT.
THE JAY WALKING.
IT'S NOT EVEN JAY WALKING.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ARRESTED
FOR JAY WALKING.
NO ONE HAS EVER BEEN
PROSECUTED FOR THE LOGAN
ACT.